- So, we lost Queen Elizabeth
this year and not long ago,
I wanna get this right,
she made you an officer
of the most excellent order
of the British Empire.
(audience cheering)
- That's a lot of words.
- I feel like, it's very fancy
and I just wanna know what it means.
- Very good question.
I'm not sure I can entirely
tell you what it means.
(Kelly laughing)
It was an extraordinary moment.
You you get a medal.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you line up in Windsor Castle,
alongside these people who've done really
brilliant things like, you know,
people in charge of the health service,
or who've sort of curing cancer.
And you are the person who
like, you know, play the part.
So you feel sort of pretty outta all.
But also you get a lesson
in how to genuflect
and how to kind of what to say
and when to move forward.
And when we were being told this,
it just for me, went in
one ear and out the other.
And I went in to meet the
queen and everything went out.
And I just sort of mumbled
and kept doing that basically.
But it was a very, very special moment.
- I just love that you
can say that sentence,
"When I walked in to meet the queen."
It's just like a really cool
sentence to be able to say.
- But we have these odd things in it.
There was another thing
that I got which was called,
"The Freedom of the City of London."
And it's a very beautiful
sort of certificate you get
and you go to a meet, I was
offered in and I was like,
"God, how wonderful."
It's very historical.
I can't tell you exactly what it is.
But when I went to the ceremony,
they said, "And what you get for this
is you are now legally allowed
to lead sheep across London Bridge."
(audience cheering)
And I get to lead sheep
across London Bridge.
- This is a really old award.
This has to be very old award.
Do you own sheep?
- I don't own own sheep.
- You should get some, just
to walk it across and be like,
"I can do this, and you can't."
- Can you imagine?
I mean I have felt like I
want to put that to test.
I think if I really sort
of took some sheep on leads
across London Bridge, I might
get stopped by the police.
- Who cares? Just show your certificate.
- Brandishing my certificate.
- Yeah. Just hold it.
Have it like hanging
like the spelling bee.
- Redmans' lost it.
He's totally lost the plot.
- I just think that's amazing
'cause it's such an old thing
that probably was a huge deal back then
that you could actually.
- Take the sheep across.
- Take the sheep.
Well, because that is for farmers.
That's good.
You get like different
grass over there, whatever.
That's probably a really great thing.
- A massive deal, yeah.
- Not so much now.
- Well, I mean.
- [Kelly] Until you try it.
- Until I try it.